okay guys wha uh welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
um
i'm getting the sound fixed i think
so
um you can't see him but i have a sound
guy here he does like audio stuff audio
boy is here
all right i'm just gonna pull up the
okay
so let me know in the comments
how we turn up and how if you guys can
hear us
also feel free to donate for the mics
just you know
i have a lot less issues if i had
200 more pounds right now
i think it sounds pretty good yeah
on the stream okay um we're at the same
level the only thing you've got to be
careful of is any time you slam
something down on the table oh
you get a horrible sound come through on
the stream that's like the one of the
big things to be okay careful of um in
terms of like actual levels i mean
people might
uh
might say differently but i think it
sounds fine on the levels i don't know
if you want to
quickly have a listen to something okay
i'll go on the live
oh no this sounds really good
on the table
oh no that sounds so good oh my god
that's so much better yeah yeah that is
so much better so there's still a little
bit of tweaking that can be done okay um
but i'm good what i'm going to do is i'm
going to show you
how you can do it said in the comments
they can't hear me
what are you talking about charlie are
you messing with me sometimes they mess
with you yeah let's get out of here
i can definitely hear you on that stream
okay yeah i think you're all good with
that
um
yeah i mean there's there's more
tweaking that we can do with the gate on
your mic okay um but i'm gonna show you
how to do it just so that you can do it
on the fly instead of having to
rely on me yeah turning up anytime you
need um
audio changes so if you want to go on to
the
you can keep streaming or you can stop
it's i mean it's still useful to okay
that's fine
so if you go to channel one okay which
is your
yeah and then you go to your
noise gate okay
so you want to press yep
so
if it's cutting out too much okay you
want to lower the threshold and by lower
i mean
get it closer to zero so you're on minus
47 at the moment okay if you want it to
if you want more audio to be coming
through okay you get it closer to zero
if you want less audio to be coming
through you take it further away from
zero okay
um in terms of the attack the hold and
the release i would leave them okay just
because they're
at a point where it's good for talking
okay um and then the range
the range is just choosing
i i i don't think you'll need to mess
with it to be honest so the threshold
that's just the threshold is the big one
so if you okay if you're sort of if your
mic is cutting in and out okay then
raise it um and then get it closer to
zero okay and if it's if it's not
cutting in and out if it's picking up
loads of background noise okay
um it's gonna pick up some background
noise just because it's good then some
mic yeah that's what they do
but
this is the best you're going to get it
without the point where you're like
bouncing in and out of being you know
speaking into the mic so
um
i think
that's probably
it for balancing these i mean let me
move to another mic
and then you can obviously watch this
bit back and if you think that a certain
mic is too quiet are the settings all
the same for all the mics i have the
settings the same for all of these mics
except for that one which was four maybe
that was the one that was being really
quiet so maybe just set its noise gate
settings to be the same as the rest of
these because it's at negative 31 for
threshold when the other ones are at
negative 52. so do you want to put them
up to that one up to negative 52 then
okay so like
i thought you said it was quiet
it was quiet but what this is doing is
it's letting okay
okay so then
yeah then all the settings are pretty
much okay so now if we jump over here
um
this one should also be now at a
similar level okay hopefully i mean we
can i want to check one more thing the
high pass filter
i think that should be the same the
other one the compressor the compressor
might be different between them though
yeah just double check that
no they're all the same okay so let me
double check the stream now this should
be at the same volume okay
was i sat here or was i run
yeah